today on the matt walsh show the aclu
honors the anniversary of ruth bader
ginsburg by erasing women also whip gate
enters its fourth day with the democrats
and media sticking to the false
narrative no matter how many times it's
been debunked and several late night
hosts all teamed up last night to bring
our attention to the alleged climate
crisis it was hilarious comedy as always
from that group plus kim kardashian is
leading the charge to free another
murderer from prison and vice publishes
an article claiming that natural
immunity doesn't exist at all isn't that
medical and misinformation we will
discuss all of that and much more today
on the matt wall show
[Applause]
you know there are little things that
can happen sometimes which though
seemingly insignificant on their own
still so perfectly exemplify a larger
issue that they're worth more attention
than we might otherwise tend to afford
them that i think is the case with this
recent tweet from ace the aclu now as
you
may know there was a time many moons ago
when the american civil liberties union
concerned itself with defending civil
liberties it was once so committed to
the first amendment that it defended the
speech and assembly rights of the kkk
and nazis
that's when it took the c and l part of
the name seriously but those days have
been over for a long time now the c l
may as well stand for
you know communist lunatics or crazy
leftists or whatever you want to put in
there they are nothing but a group of
far left agitators at this point often
positioning them positioning themselves
further out on the leftist fringe
than even the most fringe leftists have
and that brings us to the tweet posted
in honor of the anniversary
of uh rbg's death a few days ago
in the caption they write with justice
ruth bader ginsburg's death we lost a
champion for abortion and gender
equality and on the anniversary of her
death the fight to protect abortion
access is more urgent than ever
so far so normal
but then in an image below the caption
they included a quote from rbg herself
the original quote the one that their
version is based on says
this is quoting rbgina
the decision whether or not to bear a
child is central to a woman's life to
her well-being and dignity when
government controls the decision for her
she is being treated as less than a
fully adult human responsible for her
own choices
again pretty normal
we're leaving aside for now the problems
with the original quote itself of course
a a woman
makes the decision to potentially bear a
child when she engages in the sexual act
um the sexual act is the reproductive
act so even if you don't intend to
reproduce you're still engaging in the
reproductive act which can have that
consequence and has had that consequence
literally billions of times in human
history once conception occurs whether
she intended it or not she she is now
bearing a child she cannot preserve her
dignity by going to the abortionist and
paying hundreds of dollars to have that
baby killed and in fact by expecting a
mother to care for her children rather
than murder them
we are indeed treating her like a fully
adult human
that's what we expect adults to do
you treat a woman as less than an adult
and even less than human
when you propose that she may need to
murder her own kids for the sake of her
own well-being
the point is there are many problems
with the quote from rbg
but the quote is the quote i mean she
said what she said i could disagree with
what she said
but i can't change the fact that she
said it
on that point the aclu begs to differ
in their version of the quote posted to
twitter in honor of rbg and to
commemorate the anniversary of her death
the organization gives us this this is
the quote that they have
the decision whether or not to bear a
child is central to a person's life to
their well-being and dignity when the
government controls that decision for
people
they are being treated as less than a
fully adult human responsible for their
own choices
yes the aclu removed the word woman
from
ruth bader ginsburg's quote about women
now it's
it's hard to know where to begin in
surveying all the problems with a move
like this
so let's just start with a basic point
about quotes
namely
that this is not how quotes work
you cannot alter the words in a quote to
change the meaning or update the content
the aclu takes woman and her and they
take that out and they sub in people and
they and they put that in brackets
okay but you don't get away with it by
putting in brackets because that's not
how brackets work either
brackets are used to clarify someone's
meaning or to add necessary details for
example if i were to say
just as an example
lamar jackson is a better play maker
than patrick mahomes
you could repeat that quote accurately
and validly by saying matt walsh said
quote
brackets baltimore ravens quarterback
lamar jackson is a better playmaker than
bracket's kansas city chiefs quarterback
patrick mahomes that would clarify my
meaning and provide necessary
information to people who may not be
familiar with the names that i used
you're adding words in but in a
clarifying way
but if you objected to the content of my
statement it would not be valid to say
matt walsh said quote lamar jackson is
brackets not a better play maker than
patrick holmes that may be what you
think i ought to have said but it's not
what i said
so it would not be true to say that i
said it
that's english 101 i guess english 101
lesson if we can move past that
the greater point is that the aclu has
just perfectly demonstrated
how left-wing gender theory totally
undermines and negates the feminist
argument for women's rights
after all you can't have women's rights
if you don't have women
the irony is that is that in their
caption of the altered quote they credit
rbg with advancing gender equality and
then they proceed in the very next step
to erase gender entirely
just imagine for a second
how every standard feminist talking
point will sound once you once you sub
the words people or person for women or
woman
this is actually kind of fun it's a fun
game you can play on your own
i'll get you started for example
here's a claim you've heard a million
times
women earn 80 earn 82 cents for every
dollar men earn
now that's not at all true but that's
not the point
let's consider the claim again
with the aclu's edits
people earn 82 cents for every dollar
people earn
suddenly a political talking point that
was coherent yet false
becomes incoherent redundant and still
false
or try another statement that you've
heard many times you know you've heard
something to this effect many times
we must defeat male privilege so that
men and women are finally equal
that now becomes we must defeat people
privilege so that people and people are
finally equal
and so on as i said every feminist
talking point every single one
is reduced to ash and rubble by this
change
in fact just last night nikki fryed
who's uh
that silly woman down in florida is
running for governor
she tweeted simply elect women like i
said a silly person
uh but this now becomes as dumb as that
is well just elect women yeah i just
elect women
but now that becomes elect people
and i mean that at least makes some kind
of sense i guess hopefully we all agree
that we should be electing people and
not say snakes and rodents
though congress would seem to suggest
that we don't all agree on that point
either way it's impossible to advocate
for electing women if there is
apparently no such thing
now
another point i think has to be made
here
many people on the right when they see
this sort of thing play up
they're inclined to sit back grab a
popcorn and a soda
and watch the left eat itself
the belief the hope the quite fanciful
hope i think
is that the left will self-destruct
under the weight of its own
contradictions
many of us expect that there will be
some sort of war of attrition between
the conflicting factions and in the end
they'll all be destroyed right
the trans activists who wish to erase
women
the feminist who wishes to elevate women
above men both of these sides cannot
coexist much less achieve any kind of
mutual victory we think
so let them fight and and
and we will win by default
this is the attitude of many on the
right
and i understand it i understand that
attitude
it's an optimistic attitude
it's wrong for two reasons first
this assumes that the left notices these
contradictions and is bothered by them
it assumes that they feel the need to be
consistent or coherent they don't
one of the marks of a tyrant one of the
things that makes them a tyrant
and modern american leftism is a
tyrannical movement
one of the marks of a tyrant is that he
is arbitrary and inconsistent and you
are expected to cooperate with and
affirm his whims in any given moment
this is a feature not a bug it's part of
the point
especially for relativists who deny that
there is any sort of objective or
knowable truth the truth changes on a
dime sometimes from one sentence to the
next which is how the aclu celebrates
gender equality in one sentence and in
the very next sentence denies the
existence of gender
this is all a part of the tyrannical
relativist game
second thing
um and this is where it gets even more
depressing
if there is a conflict between what we
might call traditional left-wing
feminists
you know they're so old-fashioned and
traditional that they believe that you
know only women have uteruses
but if there's a conflict between them
and the trans agenda
and if it's true that either side must
achieve a zero-sum victory
then the trans agenda will triumph
arguably they already have they hold all
of the cultural power right now and have
already used it to enact sweeping
catastrophic previously unimaginable
changes
and they've been able to do this in an
incredibly short amount of
time they have they have totally altered
the way that even average
people on the street
view biological sex
um
the you know the the philosopher i think
was charles taylor has this concept
called the social imaginary
and that that has to do with
the way you know you have you have the
the academics with their theories
and average people on the street
who really aren't aware of those
theories and aren't participating in
those in those conversations in the
ivory towers well the social imaginary
is when those theories filter their way
down into society
and becomes part of the sort of
intuitive
sense that it becomes this intuitive
sense that everybody shares
when people in society start believing
something seemingly intuitively without
even knowing why they believe it
and so these ideas about gender from
from from the from uh
from the left they become part of the
social imaginary average people buy into
this stuff without knowing why they buy
into it
without knowing where it comes from
without being able to explain
it the point is that the trans activists
have been able to inject this stuff into
the social imaginary
to to craft and mold the social
imaginary in a very short amount of time
what does that mean it means that
they're going to win that fight with the
feminists and though it may be briefly
satisfying to watch all of those
feminist medusas suffer such a
humiliating fate and i don't deny that
it is
satisfying to watch
the reality is that the victors will be
significantly
in fact it's not so much that feminists
would be supplanted by trans advocates
but that they would be passing the baton
even if unwillingly
it would represent a transition much
like you know stage three cancer
transitions to stage four the great
project of left-wing feminism was to
undermine and destroy
at least in the societal consciousness
moral truth
and certain biological truths
as we move to stage four
and our cultural cancer becomes terminal
the modern gender warriors take us from
the rejection of moral truth and certain
biological truths
to the rejection of truth itself
and biology itself
that is the shift
that we are all now witnessing
and suddenly becomes
not quite as funny when you look at it
like that
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now a quick word from lifelock listen
the fact of the matter is if you uh
don't secure yourself on the internet
you're going to be wide open to all the
bad guys out there every time you go on
the internet you're putting yourself and
your information at risk payment apps
like venmo cash app and others make
payments easy but you may want to adjust
your privacy settings to prevent them
from sharing your personal information a
recent report found that payment apps
share user data with third parties such
as banks fraud monitoring services and
some even share with marketing firms
that's why it's so important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
because every day we put our information
at risk on the internet in an instant a
cyber criminal could harm what's yours
your finances your credit your
reputation your life uh it's as serious
as that that's why it's so good that
there's lifelock lifelock helps detect a
wide range of identity threats uh like
for example if your social security
number is for sale on the dark web
things that you won't be able to find
yourself and that's why you need life
luck no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton join now and
save up to 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
so i want to show you guys something
first of all very disturbing
um
i hate to go from
depressing to disturbing but i have to
this is this is disturbing i saw this at
my um we have the picture i saw this at
my neighbor's house
yesterday
and i was just snooping around my
neighbor's house as i tend to do
and i saw these here and they were
hanging like on a fence
and uh if you're watching the video i
mean in fact if you're listening to the
audio podcast maybe go check out the
video because you got to see these for
yourself
there are these kind of rope-like
objects
um hanging on the fence and they're sort
of orange
and they've got three prongs on one side
and the other side there are three holes
i'm not sure what all that's about
but my question is are these whips or
nooses
um
because they have to be either one
either way i'm terrified so i've already
contacted the fbi
and i've told them
my neighbor is clearly a racist
potentially a slave owner
i don't know what he has in mind with
these
with these insidious looking objects
but it can't be anything good
i went home shaking i was literally
shaking
in tears
and i told my wife all about it
it's everywhere you look
you know once you realize
that every
object of that kind that that kind of
resembles a rope is either a noose
or a whip
i mean it really
it really changes your perspective on
things
and we have entered now i think this is
day four of uh of whip gate
and maxine waters is the latest to come
out and talk about this we had we had
camille harris yesterday as i said an
expert on whips herself so there's a
reason for her to be talking about it
but now but now maxine waters
um who is
and i don't say this lightly she's
one of the worst scumbags in congress
just a a utter scum a horrible person
and here she is talking about uh the
so-called whips that were used by border
patrol
we are here and we are organized and
we're saying to the president and
everybody else you got to stop this
madness and i want to know in the first
place who's paying these cowboys to do
this work they've got to be gotten rid
of they've gotten to be stopped it
cannot go on and so i thank all of you
for being here today write the story
tell the story
about what is going on and let people
know that they're trying to take us back
to slavery days and worse than that
worse this is worse than slavery that
border patrol agents on scary horses
with with uh using reigns on a horse
that is not just slavery that is worse
than slavery
to prevent i mean think about this
trying to prevent people
from entering the country illegally
is
akin to slavery if not worse than it
except in slavery
you're taking people
and forcing them to enter the country
against their will
and then and then forcing them to do to
do labor without without paying them for
it that's
slavery in this case all we're saying at
worst is uh no you can't come in
you can go anywhere else in the world as
far as we're concerned i mean the other
countries may have something to say
about that but as far as we're concerned
you can go anywhere else
including certainly back to wherever you
came from you just can't come in here
because we have a process and this is
not the process
really what we're saying is
oh if you want to do this there's
paperwork you've got to fill out ahead
of time
so telling people to fill out the
paperwork that is uh that's that's
slavery
i admit you know as someone who hates
paperwork as much as the next guy
probably more than the next guy it does
maybe it feels like that sometimes
but she says we got to get rid of we got
to get rid of these cowboys whoever's
paying for these cowboys
well those border patrol agents
taxpayers are paying for them
she says get rid of them
meanwhile um dhs secretary mayorkas
is uh
looking to do exactly that
he was
in a press conference yesterday and
here's what he said he's going to be
doing about these so-called cowboys
i want to share with you with ranking
member catco and this entire committee
the fact that we are addressing this
with tremendous speed and with
tremendous force
i have ordered an investigation to be
conducted of the events that are
captured in those images the office of
professional responsibilities leaders
are conducting the investigation
we have
ensured that the individuals during
dependency of the investigation
are not conducting law enforcement
duties to interact with migrants but
rather are conducting only
administrative duties so these guys did
absolutely nothing wrong
the narrative is completely false we
know that that's that's a fact there's
been no video that surfaced of them
whipping anybody because it didn't
happen
and uh they're being put on desk duty
anyway
and all of the people who are leading
this charge they all know that it's
false but doesn't matter to them we're
just gonna
we're gonna take these these these guys
did nothing wrong they're doing the job
we we're paying them to do
and we're gonna just throw them to the
wolves because what do we care
you know there's that
quote attributed to i guess it's
attributed to goebbels about uh
if a lie is repeated often enough people
will eventually come to believe it
and you know that was
the case in the 1930s and the 1940s how
much more is it the case now
or maybe it's not it's not that people
are necessarily more susceptible
to being fooled into believing a lie
simply because it's repeated so often i
think we're probably as susceptible as
we've ever been
which is which is pretty dan susceptible
the problem is that the that
the lies
the
you know the the capacity that the liars
have
to repeat those lies
is much more than it once was
because they've got 24-hour
news and and you've got the internet
and so once they settle on a lie like in
this case
they can have repeated it a million
times in one day
and so all the people that are
susceptible to those sorts of tactics
which is
most people
they end up believing
one falsehood after another
speaking of believing falsehoods last
night it was what they're calling
climate night for all of the
terminally unfunny late night
shows um all of the all the late night
hosts all the jimmy's and then uh seth
meyers they all they all got together
and uh
on their own individual shows or or
together all all at once they all
decided to raise awareness about the
climate so
just more hilarious comedy from these
guys
let's watch
james corden and seth meyers introduce
this concept really funny stuff listen
james and i are joining forces along
with other late-night hosts for climate
night one night where we put aside our
intense white-hot rivalries and come
together to raise awareness for the vast
effects the climate is having on our
lives and the things we can do to help
there's a lot of misinformation out
there to combat and there are
initiatives in congress we can support
and countless ways that you can reduce
your carbon footprint because this
climate crisis affects the whole world
whether you're in new york like i am or
in the uk where james is uh well sorry
actually seth i i'm i'm in california
that's a california accent
wow well no i'm sorry no i'm i'm from
the uk but i i shoot my show in
california
i think that's something you should make
clear in the opening credits
who's watching this i i don't i just i
don't believe it
i know the ratings are pretty low i
don't believe that any person who's who
is sitting down and deciding to watch
seth meyers who i want to know who
if you're watching this right now if
you're watching this
and you have made the decision in your
life at any point to actually sit down
and watch seth meyers
who's never made a funny joke in his
life he's been a comedian
for i don't know decades
never said anything funny not once
so i want you to explain yourself i want
so i and i'm sincere about this i want
an explanation
even if the ratings are low they still
allegedly
have probably hundreds of thousands of
people who choose to spend their night
watching this kind of stuff
was any of that funny
was that a laugh track in the background
were there
was the audience at gunpoint
nothing funny happening there
and of course increasingly they're not
even trying to be funny because it's all
about the the left-wing agenda we also
have jimmy kimmel who's in other guys
never
and i'm not just saying this because
they're a bunch of left-wing hacks
although they are
it's theoretically possible for a
left-wing hack to be funny sometimes but
these people never are
jimmy kimmel had
another hilarious comedy bit
bringing on climate scientists to scold
all of us for you know not doing enough
to protect the climate let's watch
hello again we're climate scientists
real climate scientists not actors five
years ago we came on jimmy's show we
told you climate change is real that
it's undeniably caused by human activity
that it's going to be catastrophic and
that we weren't
with you
totally not with you
i thought we made that clear but now
it's five years later the globe is
hotter hurricanes are stronger droughts
are worsening coral reefs are dying
wildfires are raging and floods are even
floodier
so we're back with a new message and we
really hate to say this
but
we told you so
we told you so
we told you we'd be by climate change
and now we are just like we said
these people really make me root for
climate change
at this point
so climate change is gonna it's gonna
kill all of humanity okay well good then
um
oh man
this is comedy ladies and gentlemen
that's what that's that's comedy right
there
and of course meanwhile they're saying
oh we told you so we because this is
what they're doing this is the problem
they run into
these chicken littles with the climate
that they have
been before even the phrase climate
change entered common parlance
because people that are as old as me i
mean i can remember
when i was in school
and i heard about uh the ozone layer the
big hole in the ozone layer layer that
was that was it was only was being
destroyed
um we don't hear so much about that
anymore
you know you heard about uh they're
gonna cut all the trees down we won't
have oxygen anymore
there was i could actually vividly
remember a point about third grade when
i when i went home from school one day
um rather distressed at the idea that
pretty soon all the trees are gonna be
on it we're all gonna suffocate
and i told that to my parents it's one
of the many times in my public school
career where my parents would have to
undo the brainwashing that had been
that i had been done um
so there was that and then also global
warming they talked about
before before before my time there was
they were worried about global cooling
and then they changed the global warming
and the thing is all of those claims
ozone layer uh
killing all the trees
global warming
those are pretty specific
and they made pretty specific and dire
predictions
that certainly by now in the year 2021
most of us should be dead by now and
should probably have all suffocated
and uh
but that's the problem is that it's too
specific and when you make a specific
claim
and a in a very specific prediction for
an end time
just as any modern religious
false prophet of the end times
you know there have been many religious
cults that have predicted
herald camping and so on and predicted
that uh this date or that date is going
to be going to be the end of the world
the problem with doing that it's it's
more effective in the moment but the
problem is that um
that you you have set a standard you've
put a date on the calendar and then what
happens when you get to that date and
everything's fine
so now they've made it broader and now
we're talking about climate
what was the phrase that um
that's seth meyers or the other the
chubbier guy forget his name
they used for something like they they
talked about the risks of climate or the
threat posed by climate
the climate itself
now the climate itself is the problem
no yeah there's always been a climate
and i'll tell you something else there's
also always been climate change
that's what climates do by definition
that's the case
anywhere on earth at any point on earth
anywhere in the universe
if you can find a planet that has a
climate it's going to change
so they broadened it though so now it's
climate change that covers everything
and what do you do about the fact that
they've repeatedly predicted the end
times and then we get to the end time or
we're still here
uh one thing you can do is just keep
pushing the date back and they're doing
that a little bit but they're also
saying oh you see we're we're basically
in the end times we told you so
meanwhile the rest of us are are looking
around and saying i mean
i don't know we all seem to be pretty
pretty okay yeah there are hurricanes
and there's natural disasters we've
always had those
but other than that looking around i
mean life seems pretty normal
we have our seasons they come and go
everything seems okay
but of course if
seth meyers or any of these people if
they really
are concerned about climate change
one of the best things they can do how
much co2 how much energy
do they consume by putting on
a tv show every single night
you would at least you're not going to
convince me
that i need to be terrified of climate
change but you will at least convince me
that maybe you take it seriously if you
were to say impr in you know in reaction
to climate change and to do our part
and to make a real statement and to do
at least what we can
to stop our impending doom we're going
to shut down our show and we're not
going to do it anymore
because all these lights that we
that we keep on rolling the cameras
bringing all these people in you know
they all have to they drive in here some
of them fly in
we bring guests on and they they fly
you know burning all that jet fuel
so we're gonna shut it down we're not
gonna do the show anymore
that'd be a very good thing you could do
for the planet on on many levels
but at least if you were to do that then
i would believe that you take it
seriously but i don't
because as with covid
none of these people who are telling you
to be terrified of it
actually are themselves
and that ought to tell you something
all right next we have
more celebrity madness
kim kardashian has found another um
murderer that she would like to
turn into a victim and she's saying this
is someone that we that we should all
feel very sorry for uh reading that from
the daily ma the daily mail it says a
convicted murderer whose case was taken
up by kim kardashian
has been handed an execution date
despite a parole board calling for his
sentence to be commuted
oklahoma inmate julius jones age 40 was
given an execution date on monday a week
after the parole board recommended his
death sentence be commuted the oklahoma
court of criminal appeals scheduled
jones to be executed on november 18th
the court also set dates for six other
executions which will be the first to be
carried out nearly seven years
since a series of botch executions led
to a moratorium on executions there but
yo
by the way box botched executions that's
what happens when we've got this idea
that we have to do it by lethal
injection
there there are other ways to carry out
executions that would be cheaper and
simpler and also probably less painful
if you're concerned about that
for the condemned
and there's really no chance of it being
botched like a firing squad for example
i mean you just keep shooting until you
hit him in the head
can't really botch that
but we we know in our culture we have to
medicalize everything and we even have
to medicalize executions because that's
a way of sanitizing it and making us
feel better about it and not confronting
what we're actually doing which is what
we're killing someone
who deserves to be killed
but this guy julius jones he has has
become the new cause
uh for people like kim kardashian and
and other celebrities and people on the
left and democrats they've come out and
so we got a commuter sentence um the
claim is that he's
they're kind of a bunch of different
claims that they're sort of throwing
against the wall
one is that the the prosecution was was
racial this is a racist thing of course
they're saying that and they're also
claiming that he's probably innocent
that there's that there's no good
evidence
against him
well i thought this was a great report
this is from the local news in oklahoma
this is what real journalism looks like
and it's a little just a little bit long
it's probably right about two minutes
we'll play this whole clip though
because here's a real journalist for the
local news around where this the
original murder happened
kind of looking at the claims made by
julius jones and his supporters and then
comparing them with the facts
and the equation they say boils down to
simple facts facts of the case they've
listed on this website
justiceforpaulhell.com
their attempt to battle misinformation i
always like to say the most consistent
thing about his alibi is how
inconsistent it is jones and his family
claim he was at his parents house at the
time of the murder his girlfriend
testified that he was on the south side
of oklahoma city during the time of the
murder later in an appeal this is when
this
story of him being at home with his
family developed
the problem is is during the trial he
had repeatedly admitted to both of his
trial attorneys
that he was that his family was mistaken
and he was not at home that night and
they were talking about the previous
night before and that's not the only
testimony about his whereabouts that
night two uninvolved eyewitnesses
testified at trial that they
saw julius jones with a suburban the
night of the murder there are claims
that jones did not have the opportunity
to testify himself
trial transcripts say otherwise jones
repeatedly declined to testify in his
own defense julius jones has also had
every opportunity to testify the family
also contests the claims that jones was
a football player at the university of
oklahoma in reality he was never on any
ou athletic team
some of his supporters also say he was a
promising college student
however ou actually denied him financial
aid after he failed his first semester
with a 0.8 gpa
jones never finished his second semester
then there's that infamous red bandana
megan was the only eyewitness who saw it
to testify at trial he had a black
stocking cap a red bandana a white
t-shirt and jeans a red bandana was
found in jones's home wrapped around a
gun that ballistics verified as the
murder weapon
okay well
all of the rest of that is is
interesting and important because it
just shows how
uh the people who who try to make
martyrs out of these out of these
thugs and murderers
they always follow the same script right
it's always the same thing oh this is a
promising young man he was a good
student he was going to be a doctor a
surgeon he was gonna
join the the peace corps
um
and of course even if all that was true
it wouldn't it wouldn't change anything
if this person committed a murder or
whatever they did it doesn't change the
facts of the case but as it happens it's
it's never true
then you find out in this case
what a 0.8 gpa
a great student i was a star of the
football team wasn't on any team okay
so it just shows you this this pattern
and they they that's another thing
aside from repeating the lies over and
over again to get you to believe it they
also tell so many lies
they overwhelm you with the amount of
lies
where um
at a certain point people just give up
and say whatever i don't it's too
complicated who knows
when in reality it's not complicated
that's opponents of the death penalty on
that issue in particular love this
strategy because they want to make it
seem as though
you can never really be sure of
someone's guilt which is why you can
never put anybody to death
and they say
it's better that a thousand
guilty men go free than that one person
one innocent man is executed
implying that
there's no way for us to ever be short
but that's just not the case
and what that wasn't even the full clip
and that wasn't this is just local news
breaking down some of the facts of the
case there's a lot more to it than that
but
they had the murder weapon in his house
wrapped around a bandana that an
eyewitness saw him wearing
and also they found the dna on the
murder weapon
so what
that's it
i mean you're you're the guy
um
in order to entertain the idea that he
might be innocent and that's on top of
all the other
evidence i mean they've got dna and
ballistics the murder weapon that's
pretty much tells the whole story but
there's got plenty of other evidence as
well
in order to entertain the idea that this
guy might still be innocent
you've got to start doing all kinds of
flips and gymnastics in your head
to make that happen
when it's clear that he's guilty
and what did he do i don't know if they
specifically outlined it there but he
shot a man
he shot a man in the head
in front of his two young kids that's
what he did
kim kardashian and all these celebrities
who are
have so much compassion for julius jones
you think they've met with the family of
the victims
they don't care about that
you know if you were able
i kind of
i i say the same thing about people who
are really into animal rights
and a guy who would shoot a man in the
head in front of his kids
is
an animal in many ways
but in in the same way are there people
who are really into animal rights and uh
and what i always say about that is is
that's fine i can respect that
if you still value human rights as well
but if you're putting animal rights
above human rights
that's where there's a problem
and when it comes to people who have all
this compassion for convicted murderers
and monsters
who did
barbaric things to innocent people
if you have if you're able to find
within yourself true
compassion for those monsters
i can respect that
if you also have compassion for the
victims
and more compassion for them
but if you've got some compassion left
over in your heart that you're able to
afford to even the the most guilty the
most heinous people on earth
i can respect that
that means you have an over abundance of
compassion and love within yourself more
than i do
i'll admit
but the problem is that that's that's
not the case with kim kardashian or any
of these other celebrities democrats
no they they they have no compassion for
the victims they don't care
but they don't have any compassion for
the for the potential next victims if
you let if you commute this guy's
sentence make it a life sentence the
next thing you know he's paroled ends up
on the street does it again
so they have all of their compassion
for uh
for the guilty for the for the murderers
it's it's so unbelievably twisted
psychologically speaking that you just
it's hard to wrap your head around how
anyone could see things that way
all right finally here's a little uh
bonus thing i've had this for a few days
and i meant to play it and um i'm gonna
play it now this this went viral over
the weekend for some reason it's
actually from a couple of years ago
but here's the republican governor do we
have this one yeah we do okay this is a
republican governor of georgia brian
kemp
with an ad that was uh on tvs in in in
georgia a couple years ago trying to
sell himself
i don't know you tell me if you find
this compelling or not
i'm brian kemp i'm so conservative
i blow up government spending
i own guns
that no one's taken away
my chainsaw's ready to rip up some
regulations
i got a big truck
just in case i need to round up criminal
illegals and take them home myself
yep i just said that
i'm brian kemp if you want a politically
incorrect conservative that's me
oh the the cringe factor is overwhelming
that that's a cringe challenge right
there how far how how long can you get
into that without cringing into yourself
forming a sort of black hole collapsing
into yourself with cringe
you know the thing is we we can
we could laugh at this kind of thing
from republicans
and that's probably the main thing we
should be doing is laughing at it
because it is it's just silly and
ridiculous
but it's also what annoys me about is
it's so damn condescending
the the this is what this you you think
this is
this is how you're connecting with
conservative voters
and i don't know there might have been a
time when that sort of thing works
i i'd like to think that conservative
voters are a little bit more discerning
now
i'd like to think that
just because we've had we've had enough
of this of this kind of thing
but then again he did win so
maybe my optimism is misplaced all right
let's get now to reading the comments
[Music]
[Applause]
daily cancellations
[Music]
all right
excuse me i am a little bit under the
weather today
and uh it's not coveted okay
and that that's one thing i really hate
is that these days i also have allard
i'm someone with with allergies because
i'm just a cool guy
so i got glasses allergies the whole the
whole thing
and you can't have allergies anymore
you can't like get a case of the
sniffles
and go anywhere
you know you walk through the grocery
store and you clear your throat or
sneeze god forbid
and everyone stares at you like it's
like the scene in the zombie movie
when a guy comes home and uh tries
quickly to pull his sleeve down but
someone notices what's out of your arm
oh is that a bite mark
it's exactly that scene
the way people look at you
uh anyway all right amy null says i
really wish i could work at the daily
wire matt i could be your coffee runner
other than that
i only have customer service background
well i tell you we do have the coffee
running uh covered here the daily wired
i do have three or four people that
offer to give me coffee every morning
which i which i deeply appreciate adam
says matt have you watched the chosen
yet um that's the i get asked this in
the comments all the time i don't know
if is it always you asking
so that's the jesus show right
i haven't watched it
this will sound heretical uh it's not
because we're talking about a movie but
i actually don't think
that the gospel story typically makes
for a good movie or show i'll i'll admit
that too
the passion isn't an exception
but the passion is more of a prayer it's
more of a devotional than a film and i
don't say that as a criticism
but that's the way that i look at the
passion
it's not you know it's not entertaining
you're not watching it to be entertained
and that's one of the basic functions of
a film traditionally is to be
entertaining
um and so i look at that as more of a as
more of a
prayerful experience watching that film
other than that there there's uh
the problem with with the movies and
shows like this is that first of all
there's not gonna be any suspense at all
watching these stories play out
you know so that that handicaps you i
think as a
filmmaker or someone making a show
also there's not a whole lot of
narrative meat on the bones
you know
each gospel
is very short very short
so you have to either fill in details in
order to make a full fleshed-out
film or show
and that can get a little dicey
or you end up with
a kind of a series of short vignettes
which which doesn't always make for the
best show either so
this is this is the um
one of the problems that you run into
and i don't know maybe the chosen is
great
i haven't seen it
but this is one of the problems you run
into it's one of the reasons why
hollywood they don't they don't
you know they don't make very many
biblical movies
and i know it might seem like there's a
there's an easy answer for that they
hate christians well they do
but also they love money and they'll
take our money
and you would think you know why
wouldn't we see a bunch of these
there's a huge audience for it
well the answer is i mean look at that
noah movie that came out several years
ago who was a russell crowe
and i you know i watched that movie i
didn't like it
because they added so much into the
story it became a totally different
story just became this hollywood
story loosely based on a biblical story
but the but the issue is that
you have to add in a bunch of details
because the noah story in the bible is
is very short much shorter than the
gospels
so if all you're doing is showing what
the what the what the story tells you
that's like it's gonna be a 25 minute
movie
so you have to add in details and then
do you trust
that's a dicey proposition in and of
itself do you trust hollywood to add
details to biblical stories i don't all
right um
team takeover says i didn't even learn
any of my teachers first names
why would anyone need to know their
sexual orientation very good question
but then jc says i'm a high school
teacher and i'm gay
i tell my students who i am where i'm
from and that i have a partner named rob
i do come out to them yes but it's no
different than a straight teacher
mentioning a wife or husband i also tell
the students that i'm not interested in
politicizing any part of that after
any any any of that part of me after
that i don't discuss it
teenagers wonder and gossip about these
things so i lay it out once and then
leave it alone it's not a crime
they don't have to agree with my
lifestyle but i won't hide it either
yeah i still jc i got to tell you
i i don't understand why you would have
to have any conversation with your
students
about your sex life or your sexual
orientation
you know i just i don't see why that
conversation needs to be needs to be had
if there are rumors or people ask kids
asking questions
you know what the correct answer to
those questions would be
um
that's an inappropriate question
it's not relevant it's none of your
business let's get back to our lessons
yeah i'm with uh team takeover the
comment right above yours i
i didn't know anything about my my
teachers
i didn't know their first names
i knew no details of their about their
life whatsoever
that's why as a kid when you're
you know
you see your kids you see your teachers
at school and then if you're out in the
wild somewhere and you see one of your
teachers in the wild wearing civilian
clothes it was always kind of a trippy
experience because like wait a second
this person has you always sort of
imagine them as materializing in the
classroom and then dematerializing once
the bell rings
the idea that they even had a life
outside the classroom was weird to me
and that's one extreme i suppose
but that's better than this new notion
that your students have to have this
full complete picture of you as a person
and have to know all about your private
life i don't think they need to know any
of that
um
let's see jerry says matt i'm hoping for
more segments that involve bts mockery
well
you know i would never mock bts
wonderful artists
and uh and and also may i say wonderful
people as well
i'm imagining
and uh guy
says my fiance is a teacher in clark
county school district of nevada she let
me know that she can in fact have a
cross in her classroom but she can't
talk about it
gay and proud is normal christian and
proud is not allowed
i'm surprised that they'll even let her
have the cross to begin with to be
honest with you
but she can't talk about it meanwhile of
course yeah i imagine if she flew the
gay pride flag then she would be able to
talk about that
even though that is also a
you know
church and state issue
because that flag
as we've been over many times is a is a
religious symbol
it doesn't belong in the classroom
you hear me constantly yammering about
policy genius all the time because i am
that excited about policy genius but did
you know they also offer amazing deals
on home and auto insurance i bet you
didn't now you do it's never a bad time
to find ways to bundle your home and
auto insurance and save on coverage with
policy genius policy engineers makes it
easy makes it easy to compare home and
auto insurance in one place they can
help you find home and auto coverage
similar to what you have now but at a
lower price they have saved customers an
average of
over 1200 per year over what they were
paying for home and auto insurance
they've saved new customers an average
of 435 dollars per year on auto
insurance and 350 per year on home
insurance their team will handle the
paperwork to set you up with your new
policy or switch over from your current
one they're going to do all the tough
stuff all you have to do is head to
policygenius.com answer a few questions
about yourself and your property policy
genius will take it from there they'll
compare rates from america's top
insurers uh progressive to all state to
all all the top ones to find your lowest
quotes the palsy genius team can look
for ways to save you more including
building your home and auto policies
it's as easy as that so head to
policygenius.com to get started right
now policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right
and you know it's no secret that today's
today's america is short on truth
especially when it comes to legacy media
that's why the daily wire started the
morning wire the daily morning show
dedicated to bringing you all the news
you need to know without any spin or
hidden agenda it's the only daily
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're working overtime
to make sure fact-based news still has a
platform we need your help to keep it
trending towards number one so subscribe
and start listening now to morning wire
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts and leave a five-star review
if you like what you hear now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know we've canceled many
publications during this segment of the
show but as far as i can remember vice
has so far escaped the cancel hammer and
that has to change today
vice is cancelled for an article which
they recently shared on their social
media pages with the headline
there's no such thing as natural
immunity and even if you've been lucky
thus far delta could change that
no such thing as natural immunity we
know that up to now our public policies
and most of our so-called public health
experts and the media have all been
operating and talking as if there's no
such thing as natural immunity but this
is the first time that we that they've
outright explicitly denied its existence
i mean they can't really deny its
existence not with any credibility
because natural immunity is basic
science its existence is not in any
doubt whatsoever
if you have previously been infected
with the virus you have a certain level
of immunity that's what natural immunity
means
there are questions about how much
immunity that affords you
and there are good science-based reasons
to think it actually affords you much
more immunity than the vaccine
but this has also been a question that
the quote-unquote scientific community
hasn't spent spend much time studying i
mean we don't know a whole lot about
natural immunity as it pertains to covet
because the quote-unquote scientific
community isn't talking about it and
they're not doing studies on it perhaps
because they don't they don't do the
studies because they don't want the
answer
that perhaps because their interests lie
elsewhere
in any case
how does vice in this article written by
caitlyn flynn
justify it's completely its complete
rejection of natural immunity as a
concept
do they have any evidence to to present
do they have studies or research that no
one else has seen
i'm skeptical but let's hear them out it
says
experts emphasize that if you've made it
thus far
uh without contracting the virus it's
because you've been lucky not because
you're invincible or have natural
immunity which doesn't exist
carl fichtenbaum professor of clinical
medicine in the division of infectious
diseases at the university of cincinnati
college of medicine
said this kind of thinking fits into the
common mindset that bad things will
happen to other people but not to us
but adopting the mindset that you'll be
okay and natural immunity will protect
you
you're not doing your part to protect
yourself or others
quote you're getting the benefit from
other people who do get the vaccine and
walking through life on the coattails of
others victim bomb says
but your luck may run out eventually
especially given how transmissible the
delta variant is and the fact that mass
mandates in several states have been
walked back
okay so here we have the repeated
assertion that natural immunity doesn't
exist and yet no attempt to prove that
assertion at all
do the writers of this article and
supposed experts she interviewed do they
even know what natural immunity is
well let's keep reading it says while
it's true that many young healthy people
have avoided infection thus far or only
had a mild case of covet fichtenbaum
emphasized that it's not because their
body has some sort of amazing immunity
that's better than everyone else's and
it's not because they just won't come in
contact with the virus it's just that
they've been lucky some people may feel
confident that they're fine to go
through life without the vaccine because
for example their roommates contracted
covet and they didn't but amler
confirmed that prior exposure without
infection is not some sort of proof that
you're naturally immune or that you had
an asymptomatic case and now have
antibodies
ah so there it is
the professor of clinical medicine in
the division of infectious diseases at
the university of cincinnati college of
medicine whose assertions have been
repeated as fact in an article shared
thousands of times on social media
doesn't understand what natural immunity
is
or at least he's pretending not to
understand it he seems to think or again
pretends to think that natural immunity
is the idea that some people will never
get coveted because their immune systems
are imbued with magical powers but
that's not what that term means on the
contrary naturally immune people did get
coveted many of them got it pretty
quickly early on and now are at a much
lower risk of contracting it again
so vice is combining a straw man with a
bait and switch
pretending that they've debunked natural
immunity while instead debunking some
other concept that didn't exist until
they invented it
it's a clever and effective trick
because they know that most people will
not bother to read the article
and discover any of this for themselves
instead they'll read the headline which
reinforces what they already believe and
what they want to believe
and especially it affirms them in their
blanket hatred of the of the
unvaccinated
we can't underestimate this point
there are many people who
hope that they don't want natural
immunity to exist
that all these millions of people who
have immunity right now they don't want
those people to have immunity
because then that would interfere with
the satisfaction that they get
in hating all of the people who don't
who are not vaccinated
and so that's what this article is
intended to do
but if you want some actual information
on this subject dr marty mccary a
surgeon and professor at johns hopkins
was interviewed on fox this morning and
here's what he had to say about natural
immunity
one of the greatest failures of our
public health leadership has been
ignoring natural immunity we're 19
months into this we do not see
reinfections cause severe illness that's
clear observational data you add that to
the 15 studies with hard data showing
that it's effective and even up to 27
times more effective than
vaccinated immunity public health
officials are going to have to start to
recognize this because they're ignoring
natural immunity is ruining lives right
now
yes ignoring natural immunity is ruining
lives it's also spreading misinformation
but needless to say
no social media platform has flagged
this article or penalized vice for
promoting this kind of blatant medical
misinformation
no because they're only worried about
the kind of misinformation
that might god forbid make people less
afraid
and less paranoid
that's what the misinformation that's
that's that is the number one
qualification
to be categorized as misinformation at
least as far as covet goes
might it make people less afraid and
then whether it's true or not that makes
it misinformation
and that's why today we have to cancel
vice but also of course we're going to
cancel all of these social media
companies twitter especially
which allows this kind of blatant
misinformation on their platform
uh while claiming to be combating this
information so they're canceled vice is
canceled everyone's canceled and we'll
leave it there for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical directors austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there